now Austin Texas is famous Sports live
music so I'll be sure to test out my
Texas two-step
while I'm down here that's not bad
monday is all about the 10th anniversary
of Dancing with the Stars which includes
the dancing debut of Robert Herjavec and
we were the only ones invited to Robert
and Kim Johnson's rehearsal where for
the shark tank star it's either sink or
swim this isn't my helmet so I'm a shark
out of water he may come up with his own
one-liners in he may be comfortable in
the shark tank you got to make a
decision
but Robert definitely needs some
guidance when it comes to dancing when I
first met him she said show me how you
dance at a wedding i'ma I don't she goes
when you go to a club how do you dance
and like I buy the drinks well mommy
Steve looks the part as for the ensemble
Patrick Swayze would have approved
Brava probably still needs a bit more
practice before attempting any dirty
dancing style lifts with Kim one time
you did a spin that grab you're here
and I'd let go and you could see my
finger place on her hand
Roberts dancing gig is a welcome
distraction for him he's divorcing his
wife of 25 years this couldn't have come
at a better time in my life for me right
and you know I'm just trying to stay
positive and Kim's yelling at me a lot
so that's a little negative but I'm
getting used to her can't may be tough
but she's a good teacher one of her past
students even included Roberts fellow
shark tank investor Mark Cuban Emma's
gonna hang at the sameness but I think
that Robert is going to be better than
mine
no pressure now kid sorry mother and
four more don't forget to tune in to et
Canada weeknights on global